in dieser kleinen kneipe im
niederländischen ruin droht hat am
vergangenen sonntag die geschichte
begonnen die mittlerweile nicht nur in
den niederlanden für große aufregung
sorgt der barkeeper hat mir gestern
erzählt dass hier ein mann aufgetaucht
ist der auf ihnen einen verwirrten und
verwahrlosten eindruck gemacht hat und
irgendwann habe dieser mann zu ihm
gesagt er brauche hilfe und er könne
nicht mehr nach hause gehen der junge
mann hat die polizei dann zu einem
abgelegenen bauernhof geführt und dort
haben die ermittler eine ganze familie
entdeckt insgesamt haben da sechs kinder
die mittlerweile wohl alle volljährig
sind und ihr vater wohl neun jahre lang
gehaust ohne dass davon irgendjemand
etwas mitbekommen hat
und jetzt haben wir mal zu dem bauernhof
zehn minuten fährt man mit dem auto von
der kneipe bis man hier ankommt und
diese strecke muss am vergangenen
sonntag der 25 jährige gelaufen sein der
die ganze geschichte ins rollen gebracht
hat er ist ein abend hat die polizei
mitgeteilt dass ein zweiter verdächtiger
festgenommen worden ist
und zwar handelt es sich dabei um den
vater der sechs kinder die auf diesem
hof zusammen mit ihm neun jahre lang
gelebt haben sollen
und auch ihm wird jetzt vorgeworfen dass
er die kinder dort gegen deren willen
festgehalten haben soll
die ermittler haben gestern in dem
bauernhof hinter mir auch noch eine
große menge bargeld gefunden
sie haben keine ahnung wo das geld
herkommt und ermitteln deswegen jetzt
auch gegen die beiden verdächtigen wegen
geldwäsche die anwohner wollen jetzt
eben genau wie viele andere menschen
auch wissen was war hier genau los diese
fragen müssen jetzt die ermittler
beantworten